[MUSIC PLAYING]
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ:
Before we get started,
I wanted you to know that as
I was going through your book
and reading your book, I
was struck by something.
And the thought that kept
going through my head
is, what inspired you?
Where were you when
you decided, I'm
going to write a book about
my grandfather Nelson Mandela,
but I'm going to
write it completely
from the perspective of being a
grandson and, in many respects,
a son?
NDABA MANDELA: Well,
this year, we're
celebrating 100 years
of Nelson Mandela.
So it is my dedication to him.
And also, it's a new
perspective on Nelson Mandela.
Nobody's written on him
as being as human being.
It's always the president, the
revolutionary, dot dot dot dot
dot da, right?
The big man?
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ: Yeah.
NDABA MANDELA: So I just wanted
to, first of all, be able to--
make Nelson Mandela
relate to young people.
Because every young
person has a grandparent
who they can think
about, who told them
a story, who is trying to
teach them some kind of lesson.
So that was really
my main thing,
to say that Nelson Mandela,
for many young people,
they don't really know him.
They know him as the
first black person
of South Africa who's been
jailed 27 years, but nothing
beyond that.
I mean, he is the best
example of leadership
in the 21st century, right?
You have all these
leaders in today's world
who will tell you about how
great Nelson Mandela is.
But do they follow
in his footsteps?
Do they use his values?
They don't.
So I said, OK, since these
guy's are not going to do it,
how do we then influence the
young people to find the Nelson
Mandela inside of themselves?
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ: Excellent.
You write a lot in
the book, though,
about this interesting
juxtaposition of the private
and the ways that
Nelson Mandela was
very private about his family
life, but also the public
and serving as an example,
and the pressure of being
the grandson of Nelson
Mandela and having
to outperform in school,
outperform in life,
and how, through
transitions in school,
through transitions
as you grew, you
came to terms with that,
reckoned with that,
and got into a comfortable pace
with it as you grew into a man.
So can we talk a little
bit about how that evolved
and how you negotiated
that with your grandfather?
NDABA MANDELA: Well, there's
no negotiation, first of all,
with my grandfather.
What he says goes.
You know what I mean?
His word is the final thing.
That's it.
And that's very typical in
an African home as well.
You don't ask questions.
You do as you're
told pretty much.
But of course, there
was lot of pressure.
He once said to me,
Ndaba, you're my grandson.
Therefore, people will
look at you as a leader.
And therefore, you must get
the best marks in class.
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ: Straight A's.
NDABA MANDELA: I
was like, Grandad,
that's a lot of pressure now.
I just want to get by, you know?
And I was a naughty boy.
I was, like, sitting in
the back of the class,
you know, shooting those
little peas [INAUDIBLE]
the straws and the girls.
[LAUGHTER]
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ: I believe
you described yourself
as a little shit [INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHTER]
-- which I think I laughed out
loud in real life for about
five seconds.
It was extremely--
NDABA MANDELA: I was--
I was terrible.
I was a bully.
I was bad to girls.
Like, I dissed
girls all the time.
The only girls I was nice
to were the pretty ones.
Otherwise, I was like,
please, whatever.
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ: Ow.
NDABA MANDELA: But, yeah, of
course, as life progressed,
you get to understand
who you are.
Because at school, you
just want to fit in.
You just want to be
treated like any other kid.
You know what I mean?
You don't want to
be sticking out.
And every time somebody comes
to school-- a new person,
a new teacher--
or you go play sports
against another school--
you travel to another school--
you hear people
whispering, that's
Nelson's Mandela's grandson.
That's Nelson
Mandela's grandson.
Hey, do you know that's
Nelson Mandela's grandson.
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ: How did you
evolve in that awareness?
When you're writing about
yourself as a child,
and you're saying,
hey, listen, I
was moved around from place to
place while my grandfather was
in jail.
Got to see him--
you talk about the first time
you saw him at seven years old
and how someone
saying to you, you're
going to go see your
grandfather Nelson Mandela was
like saying you're going
to see Michael Jackson.
And it was just like, OK.
But it was said
so matter of fact.
And then you also talk about
the pressure of understanding
that you were a Mandela.
So how did that awareness
that you're a Mandela
and what that meant,
how did you grapple
with that as a teenager?
NDABA MANDELA: As a teenager,
to be honest with you,
I didn't want to
grapple with it.
That was the furthest
thing from my mind.
As a teenager, you just
want to be a teenager.
You want to have fun.
You want to do what
other teenagers do.
You want to be
naughty, basically.
You know?
You want to run away.
That's pretty much-- it only
happened much later in life,
to be honest with you.
So when I started
going to university,
first year, of course,
first year is first year.
Right?
[LAUGHING]
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ: First
year is first year.
NDABA MANDELA: First
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ:
Which is kind of--
NDABA MANDELA: I
hardly went to class.
I never went to class.
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ: No.
Fine.
[LAUGHTER]
NDABA MANDELA: Yeah.
And then eventually
you realize, OK, it's
time to be serious now.
I'm getting older.
My friends are,
like, beating me.
My friends are graduating.
I'm still in class.
And, eventually,
you want to-- you
want to get your shit together.
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ: Yes.
NDABA MANDELA: Right?
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ: But you spend--
so I read your book a few times.
And then I listened
to you read your book.
And then I watched lots of
interviews about this book.
So I'm going to push you
a little bit here, Ndaba,
because you spend chapters
4 through 6 talking
about the difficulty
of your identity
both as Nelson
Mandela's grandson
but also sort of grappling
with the decisions
that your parents are making.
And at the time, they were
going off and studying.
You were still living
with your grandfather.
And at a certain point,
there was a decision
made without consulting
with you that you would stay
with your grandfather
and that you would
live with your grandfather.
And then you talk quite deeply
about what that meant for you
both as his grandfather,
but also as a Mandela,
and how you struggled
with that decision,
and that that decision
didn't include you,
and that it was much
larger than you,
and that everybody
was witness to it.
So I'm going to push you here
to talk a little bit more
about that.
NDABA MANDELA: Yes, you
see, that's the thing.
You know, I'm trying
to be a normal kid.
I'm not a normal kid.
I live with my grandfather.
I don't stay with my parents.
I'm the only child at home.
You know?
It's me and my grandfather,
and then, literally,
20 staff in the house.
So I'm looking for normality.
I'm looking for something to
say you are just a good boy.
You're a normal boy.
But nothing I can
find that's around me.
And when you go to
school, wherever you go,
you are treated like
that special boy.
You know what I mean?
So I was just really
looking for normality,
and it was just very
difficult to find it.
I couldn't find it anywhere.
And so you end up doing
all kinds of things
to make you feel normal, whether
it's mind altering substances--
smoke a little something,
drink a little something.
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ: I have no
idea what you're talking about.
[LAUGHTER]
NDABA MANDELA: --to get
you away from that, right?
But eventually, it was
really just accepting
that all this normality
that you're looking for
is not for you, my friend.
That is not for you.
You have a special,
different, particular road
that you have to walk on.
And that road is not
walked by many people.
And so as you walk
that road, you
have to ask yourself,
what are you going to do?
Are you going to try to
run away from the road?
Or you going to take
the road by the horns?
Grab it by the cojones.
Right?
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ: Did
you decide to do that?
NDABA MANDELA: You have to.
You have to.
You don't really-- you don't
have a choice, you know?
People in my position
don't have a choice.
We are privileged.
Therefore, we have a
huge responsibility.
So it's hard to
strike that balance.
It's hard to strike
that balance in life.
NDABA MANDELA: So, Ndaba,
we're talking now, right?
So this is the Ndaba the
man who has grown up.
But you did a really
good job of-- throughout
every single chapter of your
book-- talking about the state
of mind that you were in.
And one thing that I
found as a reader that
is one of the most beautiful
aspects of the book
is the nuance and
the layers between--
you pick up the
book, and it says,
lessons from my
grandfather, Nelson Mandela.
And I said-- earlier, I said--
I read this book and I thought,
I'm just like Ndaba Mandela,
except that my grandfather
is not Nelson Mandela.
But, really, when
you read the book,
you go back and forth
between relating
to the Fresh Prince of Bel-Air.
There's this really
beautiful passage
where you talk about
how much you can relate
to the Fresh Prince of Bel-Air.
Or your older brother was
very much like him, had got
sent away to live
with relatives,
in many ways should be
this disadvantaged youth,
but, really, the beauty
of Fresh Prince of Bel-Air
is how much the Fresh Prince
teaches his extended family.
And you talk about that,
about how you did not
grow up in the suburbs.
You grew up in the
ghettos of Soweto,
but you bring this extra dynamic
to your grandfather's life
to that home.
And also you see this parallel
between this very different
childhood and then this very
iconic American TV show.
And then we'll talk
a little bit more
about some more
parallels that you
draw between African-American
communities here
and the experience
in South Africa.
But do you feel like that was
your perspective as a man?
Or do you feel like
narrating the book?
Or do you feel like you actually
had the understanding when
you were a teenager that
there were some parallels?
NDABA MANDELA: No, I
felt those parallels.
Like I said, there
was no normality.
I mean, for example--
I don't know-- if you ask some
people what they wanted to be
when they grew up--
what did you want to
be when you grew up?
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ: Say, I wanted
to be engineers at Google.
[LAUGHTER]
No?
NDABA MANDELA: Can
I get some answers?
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ:
Raise your hands.
That's a live
[? audience ?] question.
NDABA MANDELA: Yes?
Scientists.
AUDIENCE: Teacher.
NDABA MANDELA: Teacher.
AUDIENCE: Cop.
NDABA MANDELA: A cop.
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ: Yes.
NDABA MANDELA: You know,
these are the normal answers.
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ: Yes.
NDABA MANDELA: Right?
AUDIENCE: Astronaut.
NDABA MANDELA: An astronaut.
You see?
That was not me.
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ: What did you
want to be when you grew up?
NDABA MANDELA: wanted to be--
I wanted to go to jail.
I wanted to be a prisoner.
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ: You
wanted to be a gangster.
You talk a lot about it.
NDABA MANDELA: I wanted to be--
I wanted to go to
jail, pretty much.
Because-- let me
break it down to you.
Let me break it down to you.
OK?
So in the book, my
parents taught me,
we're going to visit
your grandfather in jail.
Right?
So I had a typical image
of what jail is like.
Right?
Concrete bars, lots of security,
dogs, et cetera, et cetera.
But when we got there,
as an 8-year-old boy,
I didn't understand that,
actually, your grandfather
is in jail, but he's
a political prisoner.
So it's not a normal jail.
It was actually a
house more beautiful
than the house I lived in.
Right?
And I didn't understand.
They put him there in
isolation to try and break
him down mentally to
say, Nelson Mandela,
for the rest of your days
when you come out of jail,
spend the days with your
grandkids, denounce the ANC,
denounce your comrades, and
spend the rest of your days
in luxury.
And leave this
political life of yours.
But we all know how
that went, right?
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ: Right.
NDABA MANDELA: He stood
true to his convictions,
to his beliefs.
So when we got there,
it was a beautiful house
that had a swimming pool.
I never had a swimming pool.
There was a chef.
We watched the
"Neverending Story."
We met the man, of course--
tall, dark handsome man
who was talking to us, each
and every single one of us.
What's your name?
How old are you?
What's your favorite subject?
Very warm, right?
So I said, wow.
This is prison?
I want to go to prison.
This is the kind of
life I want to live.
You know what I mean?
Because, to me,
it looked amazing.
Because I lived in the
village at that time,
not even in Soweto.
And the village was much
better than living in Soweto.
The village is more
like a farm style.
Soweto is the
ghetto, people living
on top of each other,
bottle stores everywhere.
I mean.
You know what it is.
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ: We're familiar.
Yes.
NDABA MANDELA: Yes.
You know what it is.
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ: --the
ghettos in the United States,
in many ways.
NDABA MANDELA: Yeah.
So when you watch
TV, you get to see
what's happening in the world,
and there's the first prince,
the coolest kid.
Right?
But you watch the
stories like, he was
living in a rough neighborhood.
His mama got scared.
Then they took him
to his uncle's house.
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ: Yes.
NDABA MANDELA: Right?
Me, to the grandpa's house.
You know what I mean?
And that was a decision
taken by my grandfather,
not even by my parents.
Because my grandfather wanted
my parents to have an education.
Because they never had the
opportunity to go to school.
So my father went to
university for the first time
at the age of 45, qualified
as a lawyer at the age of 50,
died at the age of
55 due to HIV/AIDS.
So again, normality,
what is that?
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ: What
does that look like?
NDABA MANDELA: What is that?
I don't know.
All right?
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ: Well,
thank you for sharing
that, because that's
another thing,
I think, too, that
people don't realize
is that it was an incredibly
brave thing to stay at the time
that your father passed
away from HIV/AIDS.
Because it was something
that stigmatized-- and still
is-- in many places.
NDABA MANDELA: Still
is in many places,
although, in South
Africa, it's going well.
But yeah, because unlike
any other disease,
HIV/AIDS comes with
this moral question
to say you got this disease
because you were sleeping
around, because
you're promiscuous,
because you are dirty.
It's not cancer.
It's, you got it because you
were doing something nasty.
So, therefore, you
are a bad person.
Therefore, you cannot
disclose your status.
You must hide, and people
end up dying in silence.
You understand?
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ: Yes.
NDABA MANDELA: And
so when my father--
because my mother actually
died from HIV/AIDS--
and my family were
still hush hush about it
when my mother died two
years before my dad.
And then when my dad came out--
again, my grandfather
played that lead role.
Because my cousin,
when we discussed
what we were going to say
to the world, she said,
well, we can say
pneumonia or TB.
Because AIDS doesn't kill you.
It kills your immune system
so you can't defend yourself
against common illnesses.
And he said, no.
We shall not do that.
We shall simply say, my son
died of HIV/AIDS full stop.
Right?
And we went out.
It actually happened inside
my house in the garden.
We set up a little thing.
We invited the media to come in.
And my grandfather
read the statement.
And it was the first time a
prominent family had actually
disclosed to the world that we
had been affected by HIV/AIDS.
And so it gave
other people courage
to say, oh, Nelson Mandela's
son died from HIV/AIDS.
We can now talk about
it, because we are
like Nelson Mandela's family.
You understand?
It was my father.
It was my uncle.
It was my brother.
It was my cousin.
So in many respects that's
a normality in our country.
That's the kind of
normality that I found.
Because in South Africa,
you have a whole generation
of child-headed households
because their parents all
died from HIV/AIDS.
So it's a very common thing.
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ: And
before in your book,
you talk about the
generational loss that's
multiple generations, even
before the HIV/AIDS crisis hits
in the late '70s, early
'80s, into the '90s,
you talk about just the
loss because of apartheid,
just the loss of socioeconomic
well-being, health, pride,
culture, access.
And then the HIV/AIDS
crisis begins to really hit.
Your family continued
to be, in many ways,
an example of the ways in which
you can supersede and triumph,
but also in the
ways that you're not
immune to those challenges and
the way that made it relatable
to the rest of the community.
How does that legacy
continue today?
How do you feel like the legacy
of not just Nelson Mandela,
but just the history
of your family,
and how it serves as
an example for what
happened to so many
communities, how
do you feel like that
legacy today continues?
NDABA MANDELA: Well, out of--
out of great tragedy, when
the darkest, deepest things
are happening, when the worst
human atrocities are being
committed, out comes the light.
Right?
Nelson Mandela,
the greatest leader
that we know of in
the 21st century,
comes from one of the worst
history's known to mankind.
And that is a balance of life.
Right?
And so for us, you
know, Nelson Mandela
comes from a very
poor background.
My grandfather went to school.
His first day at school, he
went to school with no shoes
on, wearing his father's pants.
Because he could not
afford to buy shoes--
or buy anything-- so he
wear his father's pants.
And that's how he got his name.
He got his name the first day.
So if a young person from a poor
background with having almost
nothing can grow, and
triumph, and become
this person that is known
all over the world--
when he was president,
his name Mandela
was the second most known name
after Coca-Cola in the world.
So for me, it says to me that
if Nelson Mandela can do that,
each of us can do that if
you set your mind to it.
For me, the legacy of Nelson
Mandela is one of compassion.
Passion is very
important because you'll
come across hurdles,
speed bumps,
people who don't believe in you.
And that's why it's
important to dream.
Because Martin Luther King
had a dream, JFK, Rosa Parks--
it all starts with a dream.
And then you work, and
it becomes reality.
So for me, as-- and
you can imagine--
I met Michael
Jackson at my house.
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ: Yes.
So talk about the birthday.
NDABA MANDELA: I met Fidel
Castro at my house, Mike Tyson
at my house.
I didn't have to go
to some special event.
I literally, I
remember one time--
does anyone watch football here?
Are there any football
fans-- soccer fans?
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ: Show of hands.
NDABA MANDELA: OK, nice.
So I like Real Madrid.
That's my team.
And so I was in Cape Town and
had a wild night partying.
So I woke up with a
hangover and, literally, I
step outside my door,
and I look to the right.
And I see Ronaldo and
Figo walking down.
I'm like, no, man.
I walk inside.
I wash my face, brush
my teeth quickly.
I'm like, no, man.
Go into a lounge, and it's,
indeed, Figo and Ronaldo
sitting in the lounge.
I'm like, what the hell?
You know?
But the important thing
is that whether it's
the president of the
USA, whether it's Oprah,
whether it's whoever, my
grandfather treated everybody
equally.
He treated them the same way as
he treated Mama [INAUDIBLE] who
cooked for us, [INAUDIBLE]
Mike who was a driver,
Albert, who cleaned the garden.
Because he understands
that we each have
the capacity and the potential
to achieve greatness.
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ:
That's wonderful.
So I'm going to talk
to you a little bit
about that equilateral
treatment and also in your book
how you discuss so much
about family dynamics
and how families, no matter
who they are, fundamentally,
families, they have, I
think you say, specifically,
areas in which
they come together,
decisions that are made
that others resent,
opportunities that some are
offered that others are not.
And you talk quite
a lot about how
that is challenging
for your family
and how that continues
to be a challenge today.
If you had one thing
that you could change
about the last five years as it
relates to how your family has
come together, moved
apart, upheld the legacy
of Nelson Mandela, what is it?
And how do you
intend to change it?
NDABA MANDELA: Five years?
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ:
Five years, yes.
I'm giving you some breath
so you can be picky.
You choose.
Five years.
NDABA MANDELA: I don't
know about the five years
to be honest with you, but
for me, we need more unity.
We need more love.
Because what's happening is
that competition is good,
but also competition
gets to a point
where it's bad,
where it's negative.
Competing to the level where
you push your brother down
and you don't acknowledge him,
or go with him, be together,
that is negative
competition for me.
So that is the one thing
I would like to change.
But also these are all
normal family dynamics.
Each and every single one
of us who come from a family
experience that in our families.
You know?
So for me, we should
not be caught up in it.
We should always try--
at least try-- even if they
cut you out of whatever event,
always incorporate your family.
Because, for me, I wouldn't
be here in this position
today if I didn't
have my family.
So you can imagine
it's quite difficult.
Because we are from a
polygamist background.
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ: OK.
NDABA MANDELA: We are
polygamists by nature.
And, actually, our tribe
are the originators
of polygamy in the southern
African region of Africa.
We are the ones who came up with
the rules and coven polygamy.
So a lot of the time when you
have one wife, second wife,
third wife, and then
those, children,
the children are
the ones who get
affected the most because
they are used as pawns
in trying to play
important roles when
it comes to who gets what.
The man has died.
He was worth $10 million.
Who's getting what?
Who's getting the house?
You know what I mean?
So this is where you
see the real predatory
side of human beings.
And so in our culture
as polygamists,
our rule is that
your second wife
has to be related
to your first wife.
Your second wife is
actually a niece,
is a cousin of your first wife.
It's for the protection
of the children.
Because if you marry
sisters, then they
won't fight over the kids,
because they're sisters.
These are your kids.
Right?
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ: Right.
They become communal.
NDABA MANDELA: It
becomes one thing.
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ: Yes.
NDABA MANDELA: So in a way, I
mean, it sounds a bit savage.
But it's got its points.
Right?
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ: Like, it's like
your first exposure to politics
in many ways is at home.
Yeah.
NDABA MANDELA: And so
our family, the Mandelas,
come from the fourth house
in the royal kingdom.
So the first wife
is the great house.
The second wife is
a right-hand house.
The third wife is
the left-hand house.
And we are from
the junior house,
and we have a very specific
role in the kingdom.
We are counselors to the
king, and we are mediators,
because the first house
and the second house
are always fighting
over the crown.
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ: And
that's interesting,
because a lot of the
legacy of your father
is actually to
unite, in many ways,
with your grandfather, who I
now think of as your father
since you speak so much of
him being as a father to you.
But you talk a lot
about counseling,
and reunification, and the
way that Nelson Mandela
dealt with South
Africa as a new nation.
You talk about how you
really thought of struggle
as black and white, as white
people being oppressive
all of the time, and
black people needing
to fight and resist that.
But Nelson Mandela,
in the beginning,
and the formation
of the country,
took a very different tact.
How did that develop?
And how did that inform
your perspective now?
NDABA MANDELA: Well, I think you
have to go through it as well.
Like-- like Nelson
Mandela went through it.
He was obviously fighting
against the white, apartheid
government, and at some
point, they got frustrated.
They felt that their peaceful
protests and marches were not
going anywhere and felt
that they need to hit back
at the enemy, which they did.
So Nelson Mandela actually
trained military six months
in Algeria, six
months in Ethiopia
with Emperor Haile Selassie--
for those who are Rastafari
or Jamaican who know who that
is, great emperor of Ethiopia--
and came back into the country,
organized his comrades,
and started bombing
the apartheid system.
So Mandela was not always
peaceful and forgiving.
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ: Right,
but then he develops that.
So how did that
transition happen for you,
and how did it happen
for the country?
Because at one point,
that's the expectation
is that he was very
different than-- you know,
you talked about Dr.
Martin Luther King.
You talked about civil
disobedience came from that.
But Nelson Mandela took a
completely different tact.
He took a tact that was more
like, by any means necessary.
And then there is a
shift when the country
comes into its formation of
having to do the reunification.
How do you feel like
that evolution happened?
And where do you think the
country is at now with it?
NDABA MANDELA: I think
for me it was really
through traveling,
meeting people
from different backgrounds.
You know, in our country,
the white people,
they are still stuck in those
caveman era is what I call it.
And it's very hard
for them, because they
don't understand that
our country was built
by black and white people.
It was built by everybody there.
Yes, you designed
it, and you had
the machines, and the
engineering, but who actually
did the physical work?
It was black people.
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ: That's right.
NDABA MANDELA: So both
black and white people
built this country.
And so I was also quite angry
at white people in South Africa.
But then when I traveled--
and that's also why I started
Africa Rising Foundation--
I met complete
strangers, white people.
You know?
You meet them, and
they want to help you.
And you're like, wow, OK.
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ: Maybe
you're all right.
You know?
NDABA MANDELA: You know?
You're not so bad.
And then you continue, and you
continue, and meet strangers
and you're like, wow, and
then you go back home.
It's like, oh, but
these ones are still
stuck back in the days.
And then you travel,
you're like, hey,
but we are moving forward here.
But then you go back
home, you're like, oh,
but we're still stuck.
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ: Yes.
NDABA MANDELA: So you
realize that, actually,
because you are exposed, because
you are privileged enough
to travel and see
the world at large,
shouldn't you then go back home
and show them the better way?
Shouldn't you go home
and try and inspire them
to say, guys, we can
actually move forward
in a way that is beneficial
for all of us, for all of us?
And so that was one of the major
things that happened to me.
You know, the traveling,
meeting people,
and seeing a
different perspective.
And that's why I think it's such
an important thing to travel.
Because you learn about
yourself as much as
you learn about other people.
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ: That's right.
NDABA MANDELA: And you learn--
the different cultures teach
you how people do the
same things you do,
but in a different way.
And there's no substitute
for that kind of learning.
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ:
That's excellent.
I want to thank you--
because I want to open
it up for questions--
but I deeply want to thank
you for writing a book that
takes us through the very
personal and political,
but mostly enriching story
about you and your family
and growing up with
your grandfather.
Thank you so much.
NDABA MANDELA: Thank you.
Thank you very much.
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ:
[APPLAUSE]
I just want to open it up.
There are mikes on either side.
So go ahead and line up for any
questions that you might have.
And we have 15
minutes for questions.
So we'll take about six or seven
questions for the audience.
Otherwise, I'm going
to keep grilling,
because I have many more
questions right here.
NDABA MANDELA: I saw a lady
there with the blue top.
She wants to ask a question.
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ: Any questions?
NDABA MANDELA: No?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ:
We'll let it sit
in the silence for a few
minutes while they decide.
It just takes them
a few minutes.
Yes?
Please say your name.
AUDIENCE: I'm Cathy.
And thank you for
coming to Google today.
Because I just want to
keep going on this point.
You're talking
about travel and how
that changed your perspective.
Is the answer to world peace
travel for the average person?
Should the United Nations
become a travel agency
and just move people around?
NDABA MANDELA:
No, of course not.
It should not be
a travel agency.
But I definitely urge
people to travel.
Because you guys
work for Google.
You have lots of money.
You guys are rich.
So travel at least once a year.
I mean, you have money.
Yes, I think it would
be a great opportunity
to allow ordinary people--
everyday people-- to be able
to have that opportunity,
especially young people.
I work a lot with Americans.
They travel to our village.
They sponsor us.
We do all kinds of programs.
So now we're working on a
program to take some of my kids
in our village to bring
them here for two weeks
and do the whole thing.
I think that's very important.
And what's also important,
just as much as travel,
is mentorship.
Mentorship today it's not
like it used to be before.
Like, we've grown up wanting
to be lawyers, doctors.
Now, you ask the
kids what they want
to be, they want to
be DJs, and dancers,
and super creators in
that creative space.
But those people are not
always the best role models,
because they don't even
acknowledge their own role--
the influence they
have on young people.
So it's very important that
we mentor and take time
to mentor young people.
And I say to everybody,
what does it take out
of you to sit with a
young person one hour
a week on a Saturday?
It doesn't take anything,
one hour a week sitting with
a young person, finding
out how their week was,
questions from their
homework, doing anything,
even if you sit with somebody
you in your beautiful apartment
in Chelsea, or Tribeca, or
wherever you are-- in Harlem,
right--
and you talk to a
young person in Togo,
in a village in [NON-ENGLISH],,
[NON-ENGLISH],, anywhere.
But our kids, they
finish high school
without even
touching a computer.
So how are we going to be
able to compete and stand
shoulder-to-shoulder
with global citizens
when my kids don't even touch
a computer by the time they
finish high school?
So it's important that we bring
this access to information,
this access to the
world to young people,
whether it's through
mentorship or traveling.
Those, for me, are the
two critical things
that we need to do more of.
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ: Thank you.
I'm just going to
take another question.
AUDIENCE: I'm trying to
reach the mic [INAUDIBLE]
Thank you for coming here today.
I wanted to touch back
on where you expressed
that you were angry at
the whites in South Africa
because you didn't understand
until you ventured out
through travel.
Now, we all in this room know
that there are parts of the US
today where a lot
of our colored folk
are not exposed to the
opportunities to travel,
and that some of our children
may very well be angry
because they are not
aware unto what connecting
with other people outside of
the situations or circumstances
that they may be going
through, like through poverty.
So how do you feel about--
how would that shift for
kids that may not have access
to those resources to broaden
the way that they may think
or experience interactions with
different races and cultures?
NDABA MANDELA: How can that
shift for young people?
AUDIENCE: OK.
So you stated that you
grew up privileged,
and so you were allotted the
experiences to travel and meet
others, even though
at some point
you were angry at the
whites in South Africa
and that meeting people, other
whites in other countries,
helped you to break that
mental state that you were in.
So I'm saying that you do
have, even here, where there
are some children that may never
get the opportunity to travel,
being that their parents may
not be able to afford it,
or they don't have parents,
how would you advise
would be a way to shift that
focus in the circumstance
that they're in right now?
How would they be able
to break out of that?
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ: What's
your advice to young people
here in the States who
may not be able to travel?
AUDIENCE: --be
able to have that?
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ: Thank you.
NDABA MANDELA:
Well, again, we need
to empower young
people to believe in
themselves so that they can
understand that they are
the masters of their destiny and
that they can achieve anything
they set their mind to.
So that's why a mentorship
is so important.
Because when you tell a
young person to dream,
and I want them to dream so big
that their dream scares them,
right--
the dream that they
dream, they must
think that it's
impossible to achieve.
Because if you think about
Nelson Mandela, at that moment,
people thought it would be
impossible to achieve freedom.
You know, when they started
organizing themselves
and saying, we need to get back
at the system, it was his PA,
Barbara Masekela,
very powerful lady,
told me that it was only the
two of them in that class.
And the rest of the class--
40 people-- said, no.
Stop this.
You're going to get us in
trouble with the white people.
When you start coming here
talking about freedom,
you're going to get us in
trouble with the white people.
Stop your nonsense.
Right?
And because they were dreaming
and they believed so much--
so that's what we have to
do to our young people.
We have to give them that
opportunity and the freedom
to dream, to make them
understand that they are
the masters of their destiny.
And we have to surround them
with people that encourage them
every day to dream,
people that love
them who want to
see them succeed,
who want to see them grow.
Because you don't
have the opportunity
to travel or anything,
but in your own place,
you need to surround
yourself with the people that
believe in you.
And we have to do the
same thing for kids,
to make sure that
they're in an environment
even they see terrible
things happening around them,
but if they have one or
two people in their lives
who believe in them
wholeheartedly and will
do anything to make
sure they succeed,
to give them that encouragement,
it's very important.
That's what I think.
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ: What
I hear you saying
is that in the case of Mandela,
he had one other classmate who
believed in him,
and that's really
all it took for him to see
beyond the circumstance,
beyond the potential anger,
repercussion, to action.
And we need to make sure
that we supply our children
with at least one person
who believes in them
and can move them forward.
Thank you for that.
AUDIENCE: So tell us more about
what you do with Africa Rising
and what are your dreams for
building a better Africa?
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ: Yes.
NDABA MANDELA: Thank you.
Thank you.
So we started Africa
Rising because we realized
that people outside
the continent
had very little
understanding of Africa.
And most of the understanding
that they have was negative,
that Africa was a place
of poverty, war, disease,
dictators, and the only positive
thing, really, is safari.
So the positive things
in Africa is the animals,
not the people, the animals.
So as I traveled,
I said, no, man.
We have to do
something about this.
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ: Yes.
NDABA MANDELA: And
so we went back
home, gathered our friends.
You know, at that time, I
was working for Investec,
which is the number one, or
one of the top investment
banks in Africa.
So I gathered all the eight
people that worked there,
all the eight black
people that worked there--
[LAUGHTER]
And when I was trying
to explain to them,
they already were on the
same perspective as me.
They felt the very same way.
And I realized that it
was nothing special to me.
It was on the minds and the
hearts of young Africans
that people need to engage
with Africa on a much more
positive level.
Because majority of
people don't know that
the top seven growing economies
in the world are in Africa.
When you look at Hugo Boss,
or Louis Vuitton, or H&M,
all the inspiration to
design those clothes coming
from Africa.
I don't have to tell you
about the music and dance.
You already know.
Right?
But everything now
that you see is really
getting inspired from Africa.
So I want people to
travel to Africa,
to come and spend the holiday.
You go to Mauritius,
which is an island
on the east coast of Africa.
You go to the west
coast of Africa.
There's another
beautiful island--
or many beautiful islands.
You go to Mozambique, Tanzania,
Zanzibar, the most splendid,
crystal blue water, pink lakes,
pink sand, natural pink lakes.
Where have you ever seen that?
Only in Africa.
So for me it's about
empowering the new generation
of African leaders to be at
the forefront of Africa's
development so that they
can be the number one
beneficiaries of the
development that's taking place,
not the multinational
corporations that are coming
just to take away the value.
I want Africans to
be at the forefront
so that they empower
themselves so that we
can break the cycle of
poverty that exists.
I dream of an Africa
where we don't know--
I don't have to--
I don't need a visa
to go to Nigeria.
Because right now
I need a visa to go
to Nigeria and vise versa.
I dream of an Africa where
the leaders are actually there
to take care of the people
and actually do what
their job is supposed to do.
Because, currently, leaders
are there to fill up their bank
accounts using state resources
to put in their pocket.
Not all, but majority.
Majority of the leaders
don't want to step off.
You've got a guy who's been
in prison for 27 years.
Do you know the
longest-serving president was
from a country called Gabon.
40 years.
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ: 40 years.
NDABA MANDELA: 40 years
the man was president.
How ridiculous is that?
Right?
So I wanted a more
united Africa,
an Africa that trades more
with itself than with China
or with Europe.
Because we have
everything that we
need in order for us to
stop exporting iron ore,
or rough diamonds.
We can actually produce
beautiful rings,
and beautiful clothes,
and not all is just
exporting primary products.
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ: Control the
entire cycle of development.
NDABA MANDELA: Yes.
We need the whole value
chain, the whole value chain.
And we have it.
But of course, without
the leadership,
it becomes very difficult.
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ: Thank you.
I'm going to take one last
question and then a few closing
statements, and we're
going to get going.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm Christina.
Thanks for coming today.
NDABA MANDELA: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I actually
just moved back here
after living in
Kenya for six years,
and I work on the Africa region.
NDABA MANDELA: Very nice.
AUDIENCE: So I would love
to know how can Google,
or what role can
Google play in helping
Africa Rising and your mission?
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ: You just
took my last question.
That's excellent.
Thank you.
NDABA MANDELA: Do you want
me to be honest with you?
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
NDABA MANDELA: You
know, I traveled
to the Google Zeitgeist
three or four years ago.
It was in Arizona, Phoenix.
And I met all the
top dogs there.
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ: You
didn't meet me there.
I wasn't there.
NDABA MANDELA: Not--
[LAUGHTER]
NDABA MANDELA: Where were you?
Where were you?
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ: Continue.
Continue.
NDABA MANDELA: Anyway, nah.
Nick Cash at the time,
all the top guys.
Lorraine Twohill.
Where's she at?
She's a lovely lady.
Anyway, so there
was a Google person
who was now sent into Africa.
And that person was
there to make business--
to make business.
They were not there to
support, to encourage.
No.
They were there to
establish a business.
So Google needs to
change their perspective.
You have so much money.
Why are you're always
looking for more money?
What are you going to
do with all this money?
Are you going to die in
your grave with a Ferrari?
Are you going to bury yourself
in the Ferrari under the grave?
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ:
I'm not going to.
NDABA MANDELA: You
understand what I'm saying?
[LAUGHTER]
So Google needs to also
look at how can they
grow with the people,
not take from the people,
but grow with the people.
You need to train and
empower young minds
to become at the forefront
of this development that's
taking place and not always
look at it from that perspective
to say, oh, there's a huge,
growing young population here.
You know, the buying
power in the next 10 years
is going to be over
a trillion dollars.
How do we make sure
that we get a big pie?
What a big pie.
We want a big piece of that.
No.
How do we make sure that
we're helping people
to break the cycle of
poverty so that they
can live better lives?
And so they don't have to
struggle with HIV/AIDS?
That's what Google needs to do.
[APPLAUSE]
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ: I'm
smiling because we're often
told that you have
to make a business
case for doing the right thing.
But we don't need
a business case.
We can just do the right thing.
That's what I hear you saying.
NDABA MANDELA: Nelson
Mandela says, time
is always ripe to do right.
DEMMA RODRIGUEZ: Thank you.
And with that, we're
going to close.
Thank you so much for joining
us at Google New York.
[APPLAUSE]
NDABA MANDELA: Thank you.
Thank you.